this video was made possible by skill
share learn for free for two months by
being one of the first 500 sign up at
skl de sh / wind / for the Arctic is
warming that is not an assumption a
belief a theory or political stance that
is an empirical fact based on empirical
data just in 2018 based off the average
between 1958 and 2002 the yearly average
temperature in the Arctic should have
been this but in reality it was this one
year is not a trend but here was 2017
here was 2016 2015 2014 and 2013 in 2017
overall annual Arctic air temperatures
were 2.9 degrees Fahrenheit or 1.6
degrees Celsius above average that may
not seem like much but that small
difference is like if Paris's climate
change to that of Istanbul humans have
lived in the Arctic for tens of
thousands of years it's far from
impossible but it is difficult we're no
strangers to living in difficult places
humans survive on Islands days away from
civilization in deserts nearly
completely devoid of natural resources
and in places like the Arctic we're cold
and darkness creates some of the most
rugged conditions on earth at least some
of us seem to enjoy living in tough
conditions where humans are lazy in a
sense though is economically when
there's an option to get the same for
less will almost always take it the
Arctic is an enormous area with plenty
of natural and human resources but it's
also a harsh and isolated place meaning
there's always been these same options
for less at least until now
traditionally the Arctic has been far
from a center of economic activity for
example the Canadian territory of
Nunavut has a gross domestic product of
just two billion dollars that means that
despite being the largest province or
territory composing 21 percent of
Canada's land area Nunavut only makes up
0.1 3 percent of the national economy
the same is true elsewhere in the Arctic
Alaska makes up 16 percent of the us's
land but only 0.2 7% of its economy the
Finnish region of Lapland makes up 27%
of the country's land but only 2.5
percent of its economy in perhaps the
most staggering example Greenland has a
physical size larger than that of Mexico
and yet its economy is smaller than that
of the
island country of Aruba however it is
this very desolation both physically and
economically that's spurring new Arctic
industries emptiness is an asset this
space is being filled by those seeking
isolation tourism has established itself
as the first of two major sectors
growing in the Arctic for example
Finland's Lapland region has seen
double-digit tourism growth over recent
years this area has particularly
benefited from the attention it receives
from Europe's package holiday industry
particularly in the month leading up to
Christmas charter flights by companies
like Thomas cook and tu I will leave
from nearly every UK airport to Far
North Lapland airports like Katella
Rovaniemi and Ivalo
tourists come to visit destinations like
santa claus village an amusement park
that bills itself as the home of santa
as well as engaging in outdoors
activities such as snowmobiling dog
sledding and skiing with the relative
ease of visiting these destinations by a
direct flight from destinations around
europe and especially the UK package
tour companies even sell day trips to
the Arctic one flies out from somewhere
like London in the morning visit Santa
Claus village and flies back in the
evening
of course this tourism ministry despite
its rapid growth has its shortcomings
about 44% of all yearly arrivals happen
in December and January making it's
highly seasonal so the region has put
efforts into attracting more spring
summer and fall visitors Lapland has
nonetheless society that tourism is
likely its most promising driver of
growth so it has placed this industry at
the forefront of its economic
development efforts the promise of
tourism has been identified by other
Arctic areas as well visits are
increasing steadily in Alaska the Yukon
the Northwest Territories Nunavut
Svalbard is tough to find an Arctic
region where tourism isn't growing well
at a much smaller scale than places like
Alaska or Lapland Greenland has made
moderately successful efforts to expand
tourism as well it has seen healthy
growth rates from 181 thousand night
stay by tourists twenty years ago to
263,000 today like many places in the
Arctic though it suffers from
accessibility issues it's just hard to
get to Greenland there are really only
two ways to travel there from the
outside world via the three-hour
turboprop flight from Reykjavik or the
4-hour jet flight from Copenhagen both
options are expensive with the flight
from Reykjavik or Copenhagen to Nuuk
Greenland capital costing around at best
$800 there are no day-trips degree
this is part of the reason why much of
the growth in tourism both in Greenland
and the rest of the Arctic uses another
means of transport cruise ships in
another video we've covered how the
warming of the Arctic is a melting
sea-ice and opening up new maritime
routes this is making it far easier for
large cruise ships to sail through the
Arctic waters into small northern counts
now Arctic cruises have happened for
decades to a certain extent but in the
past they were always done by ships like
this small expedition style vessels with
strengthened hulls to withstand ice in
2016 though the Beast of Arctic cruises
the Northwest Passage route through the
Canadian archipelago from the Pacific to
the Atlantic was completed by this ship
the crystal serenity thanks to lower ice
levels it's now possible to sail large
traditional ships through this route the
crystal serenity is a regular cruise
ship built with a regular haul just like
every other cruise ship
unlike the smaller ships of before this
one carried 1,000 passengers through the
High Arctic in comfort with onboard
restaurants a spa theater Casino and
more when making voyages like this ships
typically make stops in some of the tiny
Alaskan Canadian and Greenlandic towns
along the route one of the most popular
stops is the town of Pond Inlet normally
the only way in here is via the
three-hour flight from a Cala width that
costs well over $1,000 roundtrip but a
few times a year tourists just wake up a
couple hundred feet off its Shore over
1,600 people live in Pond Inlet and yet
in 20 1818 cruise ships stopped in the
town carrying over 3,200 passengers
that's up from 10 ships in 2015 9 in
2016 and 13 in 2017 for a small town of
1,600 especially one like Pond Inlet
with a 22 percent unemployment rate the
significance of thousands of the kind of
tourists willing to pay tens of
thousands for an Arctic cruise visiting
is enormous the local government earns
programs to help develop businesses to
cater to cruise guest stores stock up on
products to sell to visitors and dozens
gain temporary employment to help
coordinate the tourists shore visits
then on a rapid-fire basis in August and
early September the only time period
when the Northwest Passage is navigable
ships show up just off the coast of Pond
Inlet and dozens of other northern
Canadian and Alaskan towns every few
days the economic benefit of these
visits is indisputable Pond Inlet earn
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in docking fees in 2018 in addition
the benefit local businesses and
employees received it's not all good
news though due to the enormous price of
shipping goods to Arctic towns like Pond
Inlet most of the indigenous residents
hunt whale seal caribou and other
indigenous animals to feed their
families this little hard research on
its effect yet but many are concerned
about these large ships driving away
animals and changing hunting grounds
this is in addition to the effect
climate change itself is already having
there also some concerned about poor air
quality from ship exhaust pollution from
ship discharge for the safety of
passengers in an emergency considering
the limited search and rescue capability
and with the preservation of these local
cultures just like the nature around
them the isolation of these towns has
kept the traditions and customs of these
communities alive in the modern era and
one can imagine what it's like to have
1,000 tourists suddenly show up in a
town of 1600 that's used to having at
most a few dozen outsiders there at a
time the Arctic wants economic
development but they don't want these
towns to turn into tourist destinations
most want the cruise ships to come but
they also want to keep the surroundings
unspoiled one comes at the cost of the
other
so it's all just a balancing act of
interests there are though more heavily
weighted scales balancing the economy
and the environment according to
estimates this area the Arctic holds 13
percent of the world's undiscovered oil
that represents 90 billion barrels which
at current prices are worth more than
four trillion dollars the thing is it
doesn't really make sense to drill in
the Arctic right now that's because in
the Arctic to drill that barrel of oil
which in January 2017 is selling for 46
dollars it costs about $78 that's
compared to costs as low as $29 per
barrel with onshore drilling in the
Middle East whereas in the Middle East
all you have to do is build an oil rig
in the Arctic where there's a limited
infrastructure for offshore drilling one
has to build a rig get icebreaker ships
establish a port set up a transportation
and supply network and more in some ways
therefore Arctic ice melt is helping
reduce these costs as it's easier for
ships to move around both to explore for
oil and serve rigs in other ways though
this is adding difficulties as less ice
leads to larger waves which require
bigger more expensive boats to navigate
which sometimes require dredging in the
shallow waters of some oil-rich
locations right now Arctic oil drilling
is sort of in a holding pattern until
oil prices in
increase or drilling costs decrease
enough for it to become economically
viable as a whole though in the long
term Arctic warming decreases cost for
the oil and gas industry as it makes the
area look an act more like the cheaper
and warmer south the economic impact for
other industries is more of a mixed bag
though for example fishing represents a
large proportion of the current Arctic
economy and while some species of fish
will grow in number due to warmer waters
others will slowly disappear in mining
the opening of sea routes will make the
transportation cheaper but the industry
actually benefits from having the frozen
permafrost land which is disappearing
since it gives a stable platform for
equipment and therefore makes setup less
expensive in fact land transportation
infrastructure in general including
airports is expected to deteriorate
rapidly as permafrost melt and land
becomes less stable the tourism industry
which does benefit from easier access
and increased activity in the Arctic
suffers too from Arctic warming in
November 2018 Laughlin lacked any snow
to toen seasonably high temperatures
which led to mass trip cancellations by
tourists who booked their trips to see
the traditionally snowy Arctic tourists
come for the winter weather so a future
without snow in the region is
potentially a future without tourism in
Lapland in addition the pristine natural
environment is the asset of the Arctic
tourism industry so an Arctic without
that pristine natural environment is one
without its tourism industry even
ignoring the irreversible disastrous
consequences the warming of the Arctic
is already having on polar bears and
caribou and fish and walruses and rain
gear and all the other native Arctic
species
this circle is home to 4 million people
the Arctic plus a few more degrees is an
Arctic that has fundamentally changed
the way these 4 million people live and
work and that's an Arctic that may no
longer truly be home to them the people
animals an environment of the Arctic in
a metaphorical sense are situated
between two massive slow-moving
icebergs one is the power of climate
change and the other is the power of the
economy
climate change could possibly be slowed
or stopped or reversed but only with
great effort by more than just the
people of the Arctic on the other side
the power of economic pushes and pulls
is perhaps just as difficult to stop if
it makes economic sense for industries
to be in the Arctic
they're almost certainly going to be in
the Arctic even if it means
environmental ruin these two massive
slow-moving icebergs are on their
collision course with the Arctic already
and it might just be too late to stop
them the physical economic and social
landscape of the Arctic is going to
change this might be a story without a
happy ending the only positive note to
end on is that while writing the sinking
ship there's at least a chance to make
some money on the way down if you ever
get a chance to visit the Arctic which
as someone who's been there I highly
recommend if you have the opportunity
the number one thing you should bring is
a camera to capture these stunning
landscapes and distinctive towns before
heading off though you should brush up
on your photography skills with skill
shares landscape photography class using
their iOS or Android apps you can even
download the classes offline for the
flight of course to go to the Arctic you
first need the time so in order to
streamline your work processes and
improve your productivity you should
also take their productivity master
class course by fellow youtuber and
all-around nice guy Thomas Frank in
addition to these two skill share has
about twenty-two thousand courses so
it's the perfect place to go for those
with varied interests best of all you
can take either and all of these courses
for free for two months by being one of
the first 500 to go to SK Alda sh slash
Wendover for also one last note I
recently got an Instagram to post
personal updates and behind-the-scenes
photos of all the travels I do to make
these videos so if that sounds
interesting to you you can go follow it
at Instagram comm Sam dot from dot went
over thanks for watching and I'll see
you again in two weeks for another win
over productions video